what what are you and rebecca doing with
um the homestead
um surrender homestead what are you guys
doing with that
um i know you you guys are just starting
with it and like it it sounds so
beautiful like literally when i was
researching you
um i went to like i started like
google earthing portugal and like
looking at where
like where like and i was looking at
like the temperatures and the culture
and the gdp and the living standards and
like it's
beautiful like it's amazing i've been
hopefully you saw why we chose that
yeah yeah yeah yeah so tell us about the
surrender homestead
yes so um it fits very much with what
you just said about how
um you know like i don't i guess i'm not
fundamentally identified as a scientist
who's doing this
i'm fundamentally just a person who's
trying to be honest about
what i see as important in the world and
when it comes to
for me like being open about spiritual
stuff was also
a kind of taboo in this kind of
scientific circles i moved in
but i kind of i think it's just within
me that
i think i've always had just a feeling
of if i hold true to what i think is
authentic and real and and you know like
and true and i'm just truthful about it
um if people don't get it or if culture
isn't is isn't ready then culture isn't
ready like that's not my problem you
know if i'm
if i take some magic mushrooms and
society says that's an illegal activity
that's bad you know
i can give up i can absolutely give
account as to why i do it why
i think it's it's not harmful why i
think it's incredibly beneficial right
so
that that's also that same logic and the
same with vulnerability you know with
trying to
you know i want to live in a world where
especially feel like men can can be more
vulnerable emotionally
yeah and it would be it'd be a bit rich
for me to not then put myself out there
and say like
look this is this is who i am i you know
i'm gonna try and live from a place of
truth
um and yeah so it makes the life a lot
easier as well if you just
if you just don't hold anything back um
so then when it comes to the surrounding
homestead
we have a bunch of different ideas of
what we want to do we'd love to maybe
host retreats
like you know maybe ayahuasca retreats
stuff like that um
we also my wife really wants it to be a
kind of artist residency a place people
can come and just create and just have
like studios and we're just in nature so
people can just kind of
connect with nature and and all that
kind of good stuff but
yeah we're in we're in the early stages
we're kind of renovating we put this big
bit of land we're renovating an old an
old farmhouse
but the fact that we kind of find
ourselves here is
really because of the same thing we just
spoke about and
because my wife's in the same wavelength
of being like well
we're humans you know humans are these
creatures that are born into nature
we're supposed to be in nature we're
supposed to create
like this is what's good for us to
exercise you know be in the sunshine
and we spent our years you know in
london and these places
like you know you know working hard to
establish ourselves
but there was always this feeling of
like society is a bit of a crazy
it's it's sick in many ways i would say
and so the fact that we find ourselves
here is fundamentally
living from that place of authenticity
of being like this is where we we would
prefer to be
well and and the thing you said of like
potential like we know
being here will lead to something good
like we may not be able to say
next year we're going to hold an
ayahuasca retreat or next year we're
going to be open to accept artists for
residency but we know something's going
to happen we know
people you know like we're at a
beautiful location we have you know
intention to share it with people in
some capacity so so yeah keep it keep an
eye on i think this render homestead on
instagram is our best
place to keep up with us um if you want
to see us assembling composting toilets
and stuff like that as well
so so beautifully said we have the
economic machinery that is producing
so much excellence and also so much
deterioration and so to
wake up to archiving the codes that are
deteriorating and amplifying the codes
that are
making things better in that machinery
and also building you know cities 2.0
because people love urban centers so
time to build those up into the 2.0
category
and also um especially with arcology
bringing together architecture and
ecology but
um sustainability but also having places
where we literally just go
no like like i don't want to
be in city 2.0 i want to
be in um in
extreme i want to be in the most extreme
nature setting like sometimes we've
envisioned this on the show where you
literally can take
like could you could you take and build
out
um a beautiful like augmented reality
creative space in the middle of the
redwoods in california
um or right on the pacific ocean um or
the atlantic and portugal you know
there's
there's all of these interesting ways to
like embed
um kind of the like and you can just
turn
off that augmented reality space
whenever you want and you're
just back at the pacific or the atlantic
or the redwoods or whatever so
um it like to be able to instantaneously
ebb and flow between the the two
is is going to be very important i'm
excited that you guys are building it
out i think it's very it's a very
important project from the heart to do
and you want to share which is very
important and you're gonna you're gonna
inspire a lot of people by doing that
um you already inspired me and many
viewers by doing that and hopefully
you know follow along on on instagram
and uh and maybe
within you know who knows 2021 could be
some sort of cool
um opening of of a yeah an event or
you know i love our artists and
residencies are going to be very
important um
just briefly on the scientific dogma
i think spirituality also has spiritual
dogma where there's no
interest in science um and the
scientific method
uh so i think that when you go extreme
uh
kairos on spirituality you lose all
kronos and when you go extreme kronos on
science you lose all kairos
of spirituality and so those dogmatic
circles
need to in a sense realize that they do
not
represent the essence of the nature of
reality which is to drop the silos
and to more harmoniously merge um so
that's in essence what the science and
spirituality and that's why you're doing
what you're
doing and why we're doing what we're
doing because yeah there is no dividing
into two it's
it is just the one yeah i think
um that's also yeah a really good point
that again all these things are maps you
know like
the reality has no there is no god's eye
view where we can say
this is the correct answer it turns out
science is right or turns out
spirituality is right
they're different angles different
perspectives like you were saying in the
stadium like
you're looking at this this beautiful
diamond of existence from all these
different angles
and i think again i think it's the the
this the pro the process of creation and
control and separation
is can often be the thing that fuels
kind of fear and and investment in the
identity and tribalism and and
basically being like i'm a scientist
over here because i feel uncomfortable
when people talk about
woowoo spirituality stuff so i'm gonna
just assume it's all nonsense and
you know and then we hold on to our
world views like these blankets right
and we're not
and again that's what we spoke about
earlier with consciousness like i think
it's going to be a real uphill battle to
to convince this generation of
scientists
that that plants might be conscious
there are lots of plant scientists who
think
i think they are but um yeah i think
there was a stephen hawking quote that
i'm not gonna be able to remember but it
was something to do with like
like uh scientific revolutions only
happened when like each generation dies
effectively
like when there's a new generation
coming up to to hear
new ideas are fresh and you know take
them on board and i think that's because
of this emotional attachment
um you form quite early i guess to ideas
my gosh the blanket analogy
is very strong there it is it's uh
it's the sense of uh of really being
warm like it's almost like not wanting
to get out of
bed in the morning because that that
blanket is so
warm and if you take the blanket off
and you expose yourself to the
the the force is the cold um
in in the sense of you're on the you're
on the hunt again
to try and augment the blankets
and try and make a really strong hammock
for for you to be able to you know lay
in and enjoy
it it's it's good to think of of
yourself as as
wanting to and the same thing with the
layers of the onion
is another way to view is like do you
shed
each one of those layers and get back to
what is the most fundamental
of our existence that shared
consciousness shared awareness
and that also that is the
the the realization
slowly that we have the different maps
of science spirituality
yeah it's been it's been really solid
back and forth on this and
i james another thing is i just really
appreciate the fact that
um one of the things with this big
synthesis that i'm passionate about is
just
at least um whether
i'm right or i'm wrong
at least i have tried that's what's most
important i think because with um living
mirror theory of consciousness
it's the same thing every single person
whether they're ultimately you know
right or wrong or
that they're at least moving the
foundation of thinking forward
they're ultimately at least trying and
in order to break
through from being like the fear
right like wayne gretzky if you're gonna
miss every shot you don't take you have
to take the shots
so you're going to take the we're going
to take these shots
and at least we're going to push further
so
i just congratulate the fact that you
pushed and made this and that you're
publishing and that you're going to move
forward with it
on experientially with proving
hypotheses
so thank you for inspiring people um
to to do so
thank you but it's interesting because i
i maybe it's because i've been so
weighted towards that side of of
creating like that but where my head is
at now is actually kind of on
emphasizing the other side of it which
is the kind of being you know we were
talking about this division between
kind of striving becoming like doing and
i um in the past i would have been i
would have very gladly just said
like thank you very much you know like
that's uh you know
nice to be recognized for that but where
i'm at now is i would say like
um most people like if we if we had more
people
who are interested in the experiential
side of things like cultivating
compassion
working through their own dramas and
stuff like i could i could happily
live in a world without science without
where we kind of move back to a far
simpler way of life you know just like
living close to nature
um you know so i don't believe in
progress for for progress his own sake
and it's interesting that i i see in
myself and in a lot of other scientists
i think are kind of um we spoke about
the kind of emotional
currents underpinning science i think a
lot of people get interested in
kind of science and philosophy of things
like consciousness comes out of some
quite
deep existential anguish of some kind
you know and i think for me
there was a kind of very early kind of
being physically unsafe as a child was
kind of like is what
made me just be like okay what's going
on i need to figure out what's going on
and suddenly you're living up in your
head and you're like
your mind is racing to figure out what's
going on in the world
and i think this isn't something i see
spoken about that i think a lot of
very talented philosophers very talented
scientists
also like should be when it comes to
like psychedelic medicine being made
legal
they should be like high up on the list
of people to tap on the shoulder and go
like
good work figure out all that stuff but
maybe you want to go and
have a bit of psilocybin therapy and see
if there might be some some fire that's
that's driving you unconsciously
and that maybe you might be happier
without your mind racing all the time
because for me that's that's kind of
what's happened and that's why i'm here
really is
is moving you know i'm still continuing
to communicate and think about this
stuff and i'm not just gonna
you know switch off from the science but
i i definitely this is coming from
someone who i think has always been a
bit imbalanced and
his finding balance and and sees we live
in a culture that praises progress so
much that i think it's worth saying that
like it's not
physically valuable it's you know it
comes in a in a context of
striving for because you're not happy i
think
beautifully beautifully put that yes
we're gonna
have a a long-term synthesis of
as you can say like the masculine the
feminine the science the spirituality
the uh the kairos with the kronos like
it's just
inevitably um going to be uh
a a deeper more harmony harmony is
always this key word a harmony
harmony um okay let's wrap um beautiful
like
man i just i i'm just so passionate
about
the inquiry that you have um and that
it's inspiring me and i hope other
people as well and
and also it's balanced with the also the
deep uh the press that you've had to
to to embody from in your in your heart
and to
to explore what has be who are you
individually and what has been what has
affected you and
um i think that i think that you are in
fact a
very beautiful person that you have a
very beautiful story that you have a
like james i'm very grateful thank you
for coming on the program yeah
for that i'll say thanks very much no
qualification for me on that
one i'm so i'm so grateful that we got
this chance to
to talk and to get to know each other
deeper i'm super grateful and
same